I'm from Highland Park Illinois my son
and I survived a mass shooting over the
summer I am in Tennessee on a family
vacation with my son visiting my
sister-in-law I have been lobbying in DC
since we survived a mass shooting in
July I have met with over 130 lawmakers
how is this still happening how are our
children still dying and why are we
failing them gun violence is the number
one killer of children and teens it has
overtaken cars aren't you guys tired of
this
you guys sick of it
we have to do something we'll all have
to call our lawmakers and we all have to
make our lawmakers make change now or
this is going to keep happening and it's
going to be your kid and your kid and
your kid and your kid next because it's
just a matter of time